hallo ihr Lieben ihr hört das
Osterspezial die großen Tatort
deutschland-dokus für alle die noch
nicht so lange hier dabei sind die sind
noch aus der Zeit bevor wir auf die
täglichen Folgen umgestellt haben das
heißt ihr werdet eine Stimme hören die
ihr vielleicht noch nicht kennt und zwar
Sky du Mont heute führt er euch durch
den Fall des Herne Killers
ich hatte gerade den Nachbarn umgebracht
fühlt sich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so
besonders
das einzige was mich gerade stört habe
gerade das Blut abgeworfen einer meiner
Schultz noch blutig aber das war's
eigentlich nein das war es ganz gewiss
nicht denn das Grauen ging weiter
[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
mein Name ist und ich begrüße euch zu
einer weiteren Folge von Tatort
Deutschland an dieser Stelle möchte ich
euch erneut den Hinweis geben dass
vieles was in den nächsten Minuten in
Worte gefasst wird schwer erträgliche
verstörende Bilder im Kopf erzeugen kann
der Herne Killer viele von euch können
sich vielleicht noch an die Episode 2
von Tatort Deutschland erinnern in der
wir diesen Fall aus dem Jahr 2017
ergründet haben es ging dort um eines
der grausamsten Verbrechen der jüngeren
deutschen Kriminalgeschichte
bildchef Reporter Frank Schneider spürt
noch heute fünf Jahre später das Gefühl
von damals als der Schrecken seinen Lauf
nahm und obwohl der Fall mit einem
Schuldspruch und einer langen Haftstrafe
zu Ende ging bleiben bis heute viele
Fragen
wie kann ein junger Mensch wie Marcel
Heese so kaltblütig und grausam sein was
ging während der Taten wirklich in ihm
vor in dieser Doppelfolge von Tatort
Deutschland wird Frank Schneider den
Fall nochmals betrachten und am Ende den
Mörder treffen
zurück zum Anfang März 2017 Frank
Schneider ahnt noch nicht im Geringsten
was auf ihn zukommt wir noch genau
erinnern dass ich ganz früh morgens
einen Anruf bekam von einem Fotografen
und von einem Kameramann die nachts
unterwegs gewesen sind und die damals
erzählten dass es eben in Herne zu einem
Mord an einem Kind gekommen ist was ich
mir damals natürlich überhaupt nicht
hervorstellen können dass einer der
spektakulärsten Fälle in meinem Reporter
leben werden würde insbesondere weil der
Täter hinterher mit seinen Taten im
Internet angegeben hat er hat Fotos
gepostet er hat neue Taten angekündigt
es gab hinterher eine Fahndung
bundesweit wo wirklich gefühlt jeder
Bundesbürger wusste dass es dieser
Killer er ist auf der Flucht er ist
gefährlich er sucht sich neue Opfer und
ganz Deutschland gefühlt hat nach ihm
gefahren hat nach ihm gesucht wenn man
selber Vater ist berührt also sowas
natürlich viel viel stärker weil man
natürlich immer darüber nachdenkt was
wäre wenn es dein Kind wäre was Marcel
liest du da zerstört hat ich glaube ihm
dass es ihm bis heute nicht wirklich
diese Gedanken lassen den BILD-Reporter
Frank Schneider bis heute nicht los
der Journalist mit dem grauen drei Tage
Bart und den kurz geraspelten Haaren
wird in dieser Folge den blutigen Spuren
und der Kranken Psyche eines brutalen
Täters Folgen diese Spuren führen ihn zu
den Opfern und seiner außergewöhnlichen
Begegnung mit der Trivialität des Bösen
es war ein ein beklemmendes komisches
Gefühl gleichzeitig total interessant zu
sehen wie er mit den Taten umgeht oder
teilweise eben nicht mit diesen Taten
und mit seiner Schuld umgeht und ähm ja
es war ein Tag der in meiner Zeit als
Journalist auch ein besonderer bleiben
wird lassen Sie uns gemeinsam
zurückblicken in den Abendstunden des
sechsten März 2017 wird ein neunjähriger
Junge aus Herne ermordet und wenige
Stunden später am 7 märz ein 22-jähriger
Mann erstochen in seiner brennenden
Wohnung aufgefunden
die Polizei in NRW Jagdzeit gestern
Abend einen mutmaßlichen Kindermörder er
ist 19 Jahre alt ein Meter 75 groß sehr
schlank und trägt vermutlich
Tarnkleidung der noch fast kindlich
wirkende Täter mit dicker Brille und
schmaler Nase brüstet sich im Internet
mit seinen Taten er postet Bilder seiner
Verbrechen und veröffentlicht höhnische
menschenverachtende Sprachnachrichten
vielleicht wirklich noch darüber macht
er das gleiche dann habe ich jetzt zwei
Mode auf dem Hals Frank Schneider ist
noch heute von den Ton Dokumenten
bestürzt die Geschichte war am Anfang
der Mord an einem Kind was schon
schrecklich genug war aber dann
entwickelte sich immer mehr dass dieser
Täter im Internet offenbar mit seinem
Taten angibt aber neue Taten ankündigt
Mädchen hierher holen die zu
vergewaltigen die ganze Region um Herne
ist den Aufruhr ja fast nahe einer Panik
was wird der Täter als nächstes tun Bild
berichtet von Anfang an aus NRW
Chefreporter Frank Schneider sieht in
diesen Stunden die ersten Informationen
in der Redaktion zusammen und macht sich
dann sofort selbst auf den Weg auf Wege
der heute 5 Jahre später erneut fährt
die Sonne scheint während der Reporter
seinen Wagen durch die Alleen rund um
Herne lenkt man sieht ja auch hier es
gibt hier viele Grüngürtel kleine Wälder
kleine Parks und die Polizei hatte halt
immer die Sorge dass er sich noch
weitere Opfer sucht und dass er sich
hier irgendwo versteckt hält und dann
bin ich in der einen Nacht über 200 km
nur hier in Herne hin und her gefahren
da kann man sich ungefähr vorstellen wie
kompliziert ist auch für die Polizei war
das war es die Sicherheitskräfte boten
alles auf was zum schnellen Ergreifen
des Flüchtigen tätes führen würde hier
sind wir im Bereich von Herne wo damals
die Polizei überall gesucht hat das war
ein schwerbewaffnete Hundertschaften
unterwegs Suchhunde Hubschrauber und
immer wieder die Polizei Hinweise
bekommen aus der Bevölkerung und
trotzdem gibt der Mörder vorerst
verschwunden
wo ist Marcel Hesse die Polizei in NRW
Jagdzeit gestern Abend einen
mutmaßlichen Kindermörder Marcel Hesse
ist seit 24 Stunden auf der Flucht
nachdem er einen neuen jährigen
Nachbarsjungen umgebracht haben soll
Reporter Frank Schneider berichtet
damals sofort live bei Bild TV
gefährlich wir wissen überhaupt nicht
was er hat er hat absolut nichts mehr zu
verlieren es kann sein dass er
möglicherweise sich neue Opfer sucht die
Polizei ist in absoluter
Alarmbereitschaft
[Musik]
während die Polizei fieberhaft fahndet
stürzt für Janet F Mutter des
neunjährigen Jaden im beschaulichen
Wanne-Eickel die ganze Welt in sich
zusammen kurz nach der Tat erzählt sie
den bildreportern was am 6 März 2017
geschah Morgen geweckt zur Schule und
dann sagte er mir dass er das ist
irgendwie so gut ginge so Magenschmerzen
hat und
Grund dessen hatte ich den dann auch
frühen Abends dann auch nicht
mitgenommen zum Einkaufen er sagt er ist
okay dann warte ich auf dich als von
nach Hause kam war da nicht mehr
dahinter gehört dass der Nachbarn hier
angeschaltet hätte und gefragt hätte ob
Jane rüberkommen kann die Leiter
festhalten und die Leiter aufstellen so
und dann bin ich dann zum Nachbarhaus
immer hallo hallo gerufen aber da hat
sich nichts gehört Jeanette F wird in
den Interviews völlig erschöpft
vielleicht ahnt sie schon dass sie nun
am Anfang eines endlosen materiums steht
sie weiß dieser Mord ihr weiteres Leben
für immer überschattet eine knallrote
gefärbte Haarsträhne lug damals unter
einer schwarzen Strickmütze hervor sie
trägt Piercing Schmuck und bunte tu's
Jeanette F berichtet was sie vor fünf
Jahren spürte irgendetwas stimmt nicht
sie ging darauf hin zu den Nachbarn bei
denen Licht brennt und bei denen Jaden
angeblich eine Leiter halten sollte zur
gleichen Zeit beginnt sich der damalige
Lebenspartner von Jeanette Pascal F auf
die Suche nach Jaden in den Gärten
hinter den Reihenhäusern auf den
Terrassen und in den Keller Zugängen und
entdeckt gleich nebenan schreckliches
wir haben erst gesucht haben gesehen
dass das Haus komplett erleuchte war bin
bin rüber aber auch noch mal geklopft
und geklingelt und bin dann im Prinzip
rum und dann hier vorne in die
Terrassentüren rein ja und nach der
Erdgeschoss bin im Keller angefangen
überall Blut
schlagen
Stücke Teile wie auch immer das Ende was
Pascal er findet ist die mit unzähligen
Messerstichen übersäte Leiche von Jaden
nun ist es Gewissheit der Junge ist
nicht nur mal eben verschwunden nein er
wird nie wieder kommen
zurück im Jahr 2022 Frank Schneider ist
erneut im Fall Marcel Heese unterwegs im
Auto auf dem Weg zum ehemaligen Tatort
wirkt der Bild Chefreporter sehr
nachdenklich was treibt ihn an sie
erhoffe mir zu sehen dass die Familien
ist doch geschafft haben mit dieser
schrecklichen Tat zu leben was anderes
wird ist ja nicht sein irgendwie
weiterzumachen ich habe immer den Satz
im Kopf es gibt nur eine Entscheidung
als Opfer Angehöriger du gehst unter
oder du schwimmst und ich hoffe dass
dies geschafft haben zu schwimmen dass
sie es geschafft haben diese Taten
insofern zu verarbeiten dass sie
Unterstützung haben dass sie Hilfe haben
das wird sicherlich einen der
spannendsten Fragen sein in diesem Fall
um jetzt nach fast fünf Jahren zu
erfahren wie es weitergegangen ist
der Journalist stellt seinen Wagen in
einer kleinen Nebenstraße ab kaum etwas
hat sich seit 2017 verändert die Sonne
scheint und nur ein paar Singvögel
durchbrechen die mit tägliche Ruhe ich
bin jetzt hier in einem kleinen
beschaulichen Wohngebiet in Herne man
sieht beschauliche reinhäuser hier sind
kleine Mehrfamilienhäuser doch hier
geschah damals diese grausame
schreckliche Tat denn hier vorne in
diesem reinen Haus auf der linken Seite
wurde damals Jaden im Keller ermordet
hinter dieser Tür von Hausnummer 30C
dort wurde Jaden mit 52 Messerstichen
getötet der Reporter atmet tief durch
bin seit 28 Jahren Journalist und seit
20 Jahren Chefreporter bei Bild ich war
immer schon Polizeireporter war bei
vielen Terroranschlägen schweren
Verbrechen und auch bei Amokläufen aber
ein Fall der mich nie losgelassen hat
weil er so sinnlos ist der Fall des
Herne Killers der zwei Menschen getötet
hat und daraus entwickelte sich einer
der spektakulärsten Fahndung und
Kriminalfälle überhaupt nicht erlebt
habe dann blickte um die Ecke des
letzten Hauses am Ende der Straße ein
Idyll mit seinen unzähligen grünen
Vorgärten den Biotonnen vom Eingang und
den Fahrrädern und Autos in den
Auffahrten durch diesen Garten liefen
damals der Stiefvater von Jaden und sein
großer Bruder
sie suchten Jaden er wussten es im
Nachbarhaus das war heller leuchtet doch
es öffnete niemand sofort Blitzen
schreckliche Bilder in Franz Schneiders
Kupfer auf und Erinnerungen an die
ersten Gespräche mit jadens Familie
sortieren richtig böse Schreie
Gänsehaut gekriegt bin nach oben gerannt
und dann kam mir mein Sohn schon
entgegen der große und war am schreien
in der Schäden liegt im Keller auf dem
Boden alles ist voller Blut ich glaube
der ist tot
und dann ist er auch zusammengebrochen
also der
auch schon bei der Polizei sagte man
das wird man niemals vergessen können
man wird irgendwann mal lernen können
einfach nur damit umzugehen
ja ich versuche es irgendwie zu lernen
also bis jetzt schlafen ist nicht viel
am Stück jeden Tag sieht man immer noch
die vielen Bilder her
ich weiß es nicht Chef Reporter Frank
Schneider Fahrt einen Moment vor dem
Eingang des rheinhauses würde nicht
jeder der so einen grausamen Einschnitt
in seinem Leben erleiden musste
möglichst weit weg vom Ort des
Geschehens flüchten
jadens Familie entschloss sich zu
bleiben
die Mutter mit den Brüdern von Jame der
Journalist wird wie ein Freund der
Familie empfangen das Haus ist modern
hotel eingerichtet jadens Mutter ist
etwas älter geworden und die wachen
Augen blitzen heute hinter einer Brille
sie wird dennoch jung die Haare noch
immer Feuer rot und viel länger als
damals sind zum Pferdeschwanz gebunden
neue Tätowierungen schmücken Jeanette
sichtbare Haut an Armen Händen und Hals
die Mutter dreierkinder wird
selbstbewusst und gleichzeitig
angespannt du bist ja hier wohnen
geblieben da wo es alles passiert ist im
Nachbarhaus war das eine bewusste
Entscheidung und wie gehst du damit um
das ist vielleicht vielleicht sogar
wichtig dass du hier geblieben bist ja
das war eine bewusste Entscheidung
ich hatte am Anfang als war weggefahren
sind das Gefühl ich lass ihn mir zurück
ich was in den Stich und ja aus der
Entscheidung her
wollte ich auch hier wohnen bleiben und
für mich was definitiv die bessere
Entscheidungen außer sich die
Entscheidung getroffen habe jetzt nicht
in diesem Keller zu leben würde das noch
mit dem Kopf sitzen weiß jeder hat ja
auch beim Nachbarin im Keller war und
das war noch nie was sein Sohn ähm
glaube ich würde ich jetzt nicht mehr
hier sitzen wie geht es dem Menschen die
Jaden gefunden haben
draußen genauso Momente wie bei mir auch
wo halt Depressionen hochkommen und
wo es halt schwierig ist so mit der
Psyche klar zu kommen ja
wir lenken uns ab das funktioniert zwar
nicht immer aber
man hat es dann so ein bisschen besser
im Griff und ähm wenn es dir nicht gut
geht sagen diesmal wir reden dann
darüber weil ja man das einfach für die
Psyche braucht reden ist wichtig und
vielleicht umso wichtiger mit einem
gewissen zeitlichen Abstand der Chef
Reporter erzählt jadens Mutter von
seinem Plan den Fall und den Täter noch
einmal genauer zu betrachten sie begrüßt
das Vorhaben grundsätzlich stellt aber
in Bezug auf den verurteilten Mörder
schlicht fest
es ist aber er hat noch leben
ich habe jetzt gerade mit James Mutter
gesprochen und muss sagen ich bin immer
noch beeindruckt von der Frau wie stark
sie ist wie sie versucht mit der
Situation umzugehen wie sie immer noch
für ihre anderen Kinder da ist und wie
sie aber auch ehrlich gesagt hat wie
Situationen in ihrem Leben gab wo sie
dachte es geht einfach nicht weiter und
man merkt ihr an obwohl sie so stark ist
wie es immer noch Situationen gibt
darüber kann sie kaum sprechen dann
versagt ihr doch die Stimme es kommt
Training in ihrer Augen und ich kann es
nur zu gut nachvollziehen ich bin selber
Vater und wenn ich mir vorstelle dass
dieser Frau wieder fahren ist kann ich
immer nur sagen ich bin beeindruckt von
ihrer Stärke und dieses geschafft hat
trotzdem weiterzuleben
Frank Schneider macht einen kleinen
Umweg über die A43 obwohl er eigentlich
nur direkt hinein nach Bochum möchte er
gibt kräftig Gas und ordnet sich in den
Verkehr ein der Umweg hilft der
Journalist kann bei monotonen Autofahren
die Gedankengut fokussieren wer war
dieser Marcel 2017 gerade einmal 19
Jahre alt die haben alle gesagt für uns
war ein harmloser idiotischer Spinner
der sich wichtigsten Tagen vielleicht
war das sogar der Auslöser dass Marcel
beweisen wollte ich bin gefährlich ich
bin nicht der über den er lacht jetzt
zeige ich euch mal was ich alles machen
kann hätte wirklich keine Gefühle hat er
keine Reue um dieser Frage noch mal
nachzugehen trifft Frank Schneider einen
alten Bekannten fragt sich auch wie ist
ein junger Mensch in der Lage sowas zu
tun
ich bin jetzt hier vor dem
Polizeipräsidium in Bochum habe jetzt
einen Termin mit Hauptkommissar Volker
Schütte er war damals Pressesprecher hat
damals die Fahndung mit betreut nach
Marcel Heese und er kann mir noch mal
erzählen wie der Stand der Ermittlungen
damals war und wie er damals die
Situation diese Großfahndung erlebt hat
das Backsteingebäude mit den frisch
gestrichenen weißen Fensterrahmen hat
der Reporte in seiner langen Karriere
schon unzählige Male betreten er würde
sich quasi mit verbundenen Augen
zurechtfinden aber Hauptkommissar Volker
Schütte empfängt den Journalisten im
Foyer und begleitet ihn durch das
Treppenhaus warum war dieses Verbrechen
für sie so einschneiden der es war diese
Brutalität die man dann sich nicht nur
vorstellen konnte man konnte sich das ja
auch Anschauen im Internet ja wir haben
die Bilder ja dann auch gesehen die im
Internet veröffentlicht worden sind mir
war es auch nicht bewusst dass man die
so schnell ins Internet hochgeladen hat
wir sind auch in den ersten Stunden vom
Darknet ausgegangen und erst später an
dem Tag wussten wir dann dass es diese
Plattform ist wo wir dann natürlich auch
gestöbert haben und einfach entsetzt
waren was für Widerlichkeiten wir dort
gesehen haben nicht nur Fotos gepostet
er hat auch audiobo Botschaft also
Sprachnachrichten verschickt in denen er
unglaublich eiskalt über die Taten
gesprochen hat sich auch lustig gemacht
hat über die Taten auf einem Tablet
schauen sich die beiden Männer die
chatverläufe der Tatnacht
angemacht gar nicht so besonders
der Polizist scrollt durch die Datenbank
auch da war ja dann irgendwann der Satz
ist ich mache ich muss was knastwürdiges
machen also sehr schnell kam jeder
Gedanke das ist alles glaubwürdig
Grund
[Musik]
das Tablet wird kurz zur Seite gelegt
nachdenklich fährt sich der Fahne
Hauptkommissar über das Kind sind ja
auch schon Kinder ermordet worden es hat
auch schon schlimme kapitalelikte
gegeben auch schon wirklich
deutschlandweit bekannt aber hier war es
ein kleiner Junge und der Täter war
flüchtig ähm man konnte die Sache es
bedingt einschätzen wir haben es dann
aber gemerkt was für ein Drive diese
Geschichte genommen hat auch bei den
Medien es kam sehr schnell rüber hier
ist ein ganz ganz gefährlicher Mensch
unterwegs und ja dann sind auch hier die
Sorge an den Präsidium was ist gibt es
möglicherweise weitere Daten der
Bild-Chef Reporter nickt langsam und
lehnt sich zurück diese Zeit damals war
für uns auch wirklich ja schon sehr
herausfordert sehr anstrengend auch weil
es ja keine Ruhepausen gab immer wieder
kam auch neue Nachrichten von dem Täter
und man musste ja wie gesagt immer nicht
gibt es bereits weitere Opfer wie viel
Opfer gibt es noch was kommt als
nächstes vom Täter auf dem Tablet wird
ein weiterer Clip abgespielt
da habe ich jetzt zwei Mode auf dem Hals
diese Sprachnachrichten und Fotos
konnten sich damals alle im Netz anhören
und ansehen
unsicherheit macht sich daraufhin in der
ganzen Region um Herne bereit vielleicht
hat der Killer ja Schusswaffen
vielleicht ist er ein Amokläufer ein
Terrorist die straßenbahnmenschen leeren
Menschen an Angst die waren auch
tagsüber fast leer also wirklich schon
schon ganz beängstigende Szenen die sich
abgespielt haben weil ja auch wirklich
keiner wusste was macht er als nächstes
denn er gab ja immer mehr oder weniger
damit an dass er noch sich weitere Opfer
suchen will und betont hier auch dass
ihm gar nichts ausmachen würde Menschen
zu töten aber das jetzt gemacht und das
war ja ganz leicht und das macht ihm
nichts und deshalb war die Angst
natürlich bei den Menschen und die Sorge
sehr sehr groß nachdem Marcel Heße den
neunjährigen Jaden auf bestialische
Weise ermordet hat kann sich der Täter
nicht entscheiden was er als nächstes
tun soll ja dann hat er einen Fußmarsch
hingelegt werden Hubschrauber fliegen
lassen Hunde sind eingesetzt worden
leider haben wir Marcel Hesse nicht mehr
erwischt er brauchte nur diese fünf bis
sechs Kilometer zu einem ja Freund will
ich gar nicht mal sagen zu einem
Bekannten den er wohl aus
kollegschulzeiten kannte den Christopher
und hat ihm dann wohl die Geschichte
erzählt hör mal meine Eltern sind
umgezogen ich komme da alles noch nicht
so klar kann ich möglicherweise mal für
zwei drei Tage bei dir übernachten dann
hat man zusammen Karten gespielt man hat
zusammen Filme geguckt und hat sich
zusammen gegen 2 Uhr schlafen gelegt es
sollte die letzte Nacht im Leben des
22-Jährigen Christopher we sein der
sympathische Lockenkopf kann nicht ahnen
zu welchem Wahnsinn sein gastfähig ist
ja und irgendwann ist wahrscheinlich
dann dieser Christopher morgens wach
geworden und wie junge Menschen das
machen man schaut mal kurz ins Netz und
dann sieht er das Foto seines Kumpels
Marcel Hesse der direkt neben ihm noch
schläft ja weckt ihn wohl und ja ich
glaube das war das Todesurteil der junge
Mann ist sicherlich grausames gequält
worden also wieder eine widerwärtige Tat
die auch hier passiert ist
der Reporter setzt sich wieder ins Auto
und fährt zurück nach Herne diesmal
mitten in die Stadt mit ihren eng
stehenden Gründerzeithäusern wir sind
hier in der Sedanstraße in Herne in
diesem Mehrfamilienhaus hier oben im
ersten Stock hat er sich damals bei
seinem Kumpel Christopher versteckt und
hat sich dort zwei Tage verborgen
gehalten die Anwohner hier in der ganzen
Straße keiner wusste dass er sich hier
versteckt hält Frank Schneider steigt
die alten Knarren Holzstufen in dem
Hausflur nach oben es ist düster und
muffig das fahle gelbe Licht lässt alles
schäbig wirken ich gehe jetzt noch mal
zu diesem zweiten Tatort und möchte mit
den Anwohnern noch mal sprechen die
damals selber Lebensgefahr waren
hier oben ist Masse eine Hilfe damals
auch hochgegangen an dem Abend der
ersten Tag hier vorne ist die
Wohnungstür von der Wohnung und der
damals Christopher wohnte als der
Journalist die Treppen wieder
hinuntergeht erinnerte sich damals mit
einer Nachbarin gesprochen zu haben sie
kannte Christopher sie kannte seine
Mutter sie kennt die ganzen Hintergründe
auch das falls Schneide versucht es
erneut und klingelt an einer der Türen
ein kurzes Gespräch auf dem
Treppenabsatz ergibt sich die ältere
Frau erinnert sich noch an den Tag der
für sie ganz normal begann haben Sie
denn damals irgendwas verdächtig das war
zufällig mitbekommen vielleicht
Geräusche ich bin morgen zur Arbeit
gegangen wie immer um 8 Uhr und da habe
ich da oben was ziemlich laut und Streit
und da wollte ich erst aufgehen aber ich
hatte es auch eigentlich an dem Morgen
und habe gesagt naja junge Leute
streiten sich auch mal abnehmen an der
Nachbar der hat die Hilfe gehört aber er
wusste nicht woher sie kommen was war
der Christopher denn sie haben ja lange
mit ihm hier gelebt fünf Mensch ein Typ
wie würden sie ihn beschreiben
[Musik]
das vielleicht auch der Grund gewesen
warum er den reingelassen hat ne bei dem
helfen wollte nicht vielleicht auch zu
leichtgläubig ne müssen Sie ihn heute
immer noch wieder dran denken an das was
damals passiert ist klar das hört sich
jetzt blöd an nee aber wenn ich jetzt im
Keller gehe oder so ich nehme immer ein
Pfefferspray mit weil ich bin mir jetzt
ganz sicher die Leute waren alle zu
Hause hier und der Junge hat um Hilfe
geschehen und es hat ihn hier im Haus
keiner gehört das ist so ein schlimmer
Gedanke dass jemand um sein Leben um
Hilfe schreit und ihn keiner
[Musik]
fürchterlich aber noch einmal zurück zum
Kommissariat in Bochum und zu Volker
Schütte der den weiteren Verlauf vom
wüten des Marcel heses skizziert in
unmittelbarer Nähe hat es ein Brand
gegeben in einem Wohnhaus als die
Feuerwehr den Brand gelöscht hat oder
beim Löschen sind da Leichen entdeckt
worden die Polizei schwer bewaffnete
Hundertschaften sek alle haben ihn
gesucht Marcel Häschen wurde quer durch
die Republik mehr oder weniger verfolgt
und er versteckte sich die ganze Zeit in
dieser Wohnung und am Ende war es dann
so dass irgendwann kein Ausweg mehr sah
hat in der Wohnung Feuer gelegt
vielleicht ist sein Hass auf die
Menschheit nach der Gewalt Orgie
verraucht befriedigt durch zwei Morde an
unschuldigen oder ist der Herne Killer
einfach nur auf Anerkennung aus
jedenfalls nutzt der zweifache Mörder
den PC des Toten Christopher um sich
erneut mit seinen Taten im Netz zu
brüsten
Volker Schütte und der Reporter Scrollen
durch die letzten Post des Mörders man
fragt sich auch wie ist ein junger
Mensch in der Lage
zu tun wie ist man in der Lage direkt
danach sich wieder an einen Rechner zu
setzen Fotos einzustellen und durchaus
geschliffene Worte zu schreiben auf
einem Foto kann ich mich noch erinnern
das fand ich so unglaublich
unvorstellbar dass ein Stück Pizza da
lag auf was er offenbar auf oder neben
der Leiche Pizza gegessen hatte es war
unvorstellbar man fragte sie mal was
geht in so einem Menschen vor der Mörder
liegt die lettantisch einen Brand
vielleicht um seine Spuren zu verwischen
vielleicht einfach aus Langeweile dann
verlässt er die Wohnung seines Opfers
Christopher weh
[Musik]
wir kommen zu einem daily Spezial heute
Abend endlich sie haben ihn der
mutmaßliche kinderkiller Marcel hesse
hat sich heute Abend in einem
Schnellimbiss der Polizei gestellt
wir waren heilfroh wirklich alle
heilfroh als dann an diesem
Donnerstagabend der erlösende anruft kam
wir haben ihn und ich glaube das ganze
Präsidium nicht nur das Präsidium in
Bochum sondern auch dortmund und auch
die Bevölkerung war heilfroh diesen
Menschen gefasst zu haben auch diesen
Ort besucht Chefredakteur Frank
Schneider 5 Jahre nach den Norden noch
mal den Imbiss Thessaloniki griechische
Spezialitäten gibt es noch immer
nur 200 Meter entfernt vom letzten
Tatort gegen Marcel Hesse an dem Abend
genau dieses Stück hier auf dem Gehweg
zu diesem Imbiss hier vorne und stellte
sich dort er sagte damals zu dem wird
ich bin der gesuchte Marcel rufen Sie
die Polizei der Täter ist gefasst die
blutige Reise des Marcel Heese ist zu
Ende die Verarbeitung seiner unfassbaren
Taten beginnt nun aber erst wie hat das
die Menschen mitgenommen Herne diese Tat
und auch ihre Kollegen gab es da auch
nach Betreuung oder musste die sogar
sein Hauptkommissar Volker Schütte denkt
einen Moment nach geht in sich wir haben
da einen Termin in einer Schule wo
Seelsorger sich um die Kinder
gekümmert haben die mit dem Jaden
zusammen in die Schule gegangen sind das
war für mich eine Veranstaltung ich muss
sagen dabei Gänsehaut Feeling was für
eine Angst da noch da war auch Kollegen
von uns mussten natürlich betreut werden
das sind Bilder für junge Polizisten
waren mit am Tatort unsere
Spurensicherung die haben das natürlich
ich sag jetzt mal ganz platt mit voller
Br Seite sehen müssen diese Bilder die
auch die Angehörigen von Jaden oder die
Helfer gesehen haben wie dieser kleine
Junge danach und leider haben es auch
Millionen Menschen wahrscheinlich sich
auch im Internet angeguckt einfach
widerlich einfach verwerflich es hat in
dem Fall eben auch nur Verlierer gegeben
die Ehe der Eltern von Jaden ist dann
zerbrochen die Mutter von Christopher
den zweiten Opfer ist mehr oder weniger
auch an Kummer danach gestorben der
Leiter der Mordkommission die nicht
viele viele Jahre kennen der viel
gesehen hat der hat gesoffen war dieser
Fall hat den auch so nachhaltig
betroffen gemacht
hinterher seinen Job innerhalb der
Polizei hingeworfen hat was anderes
gemacht hat ich kann das nicht mehr ich
will das nicht mehr
es gab nicht nur die beiden getöteten
Menschen die zu Opfern des Verbrechens
wurden auch die Familie jadens wird sich
kaum von dieser Tat an ihrem Sohn Bruder
Enkel erholen und auch die Familie des
Täters wird zum Opfer der Tat wir fahren
jetzt zu der Wohnung der Mutter des
Täters Marcel Hesse wir haben damals
kurz nach der Tat versucht Kontakt zu
der Mutter aufzunehmen wir haben sie
dann auch erreicht und nach langen
Vorgesprächen hat sich auch bereit
erklärt und erkennbar vor der Kamera mit
uns zu sprechen das heißt mit dem Rücken
zur Kamera weil sie einfach große Scham
empfand großen Schmerzen natürlich auch
in der Küche für Michaela l sitzt der
Reporter damals der Mutter des Herne
Killers gegenüber wie war der Tag an dem
sozusagen ihr Leben sich leider
nachhaltig verändert hat
Anne ich werde auch da übernachten ich
habe das natürlich geglaubt dass die
Nachbarin mich anrief die Jenny sagte
sie du bei dir im Hausbrand noch Licht
weil ich kann nicht sein
da brennt Licht und dein Sohn war da
deine Leiter geholt und sich das hörte
dachte ich zuerst hmm der wird ja wohl
nicht versucht haben die Lampe von der
Decke abzukriegen und dachte ein Unfall
und ich hätte nie
wäre absolut nicht und ich weiß wie das
sein muss als Mutter
wenn man seine Kinder verliert
so weit die aktuelle Bestandsaufnahme
Reporter Frank Schneider fragt sich aber
wie der Täter nach fünf Jahren
Strafvollzug über seine Morde denkt er
will den Mörder treffen
ins Gefängnis er hat auch relativ prompt
darauf reagiert und mir geantwortet und
jetzt ist aus dem Briefverkehr
entstanden dass wir uns treffen werden
dass wir gemeinsam in der JVA uns mal
unterhalten können persönlich was Marcel
Heese ihm im Vorfeld auf diesen Brief
antwortet und was der BILD-Reporter
Frank Schneider im Gefängnis über die
Gedankenwelt des Mörders erfährt das
hört ihr in der nächsten Folge von
Tatort Deutschland bis dahin euer Sky
Demo
[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland ist eine Produktion
aus den Wake world Studios
Projektleitung Simone terrak Produktion
Fabian Scheffler Drehbuch Lutz Neumann
Redaktion Bild Frank Schneider und
Stefan
und wer Teil 2 jetzt direkt weiter hören
möchte sucht hier im Channel einfach
nach beim Kindermörder im Gefängnis